bond enthalpy is the change in enthalpy
or delta h for breaking a particular
bond in one mole of a gaseous substance
if we think about the diatomic chlorine
molecule so cl2 down here is a little
picture of cl2 each of the green spheres
as a chlorine atom and they're bonded
together by a single covalent bond it
would take energy to break this bond in
diatomic chlorine gas and turn diatomic
chlorine gas cl2 into two individual
chlorine atoms so we're going from cl2
in the gaseous state to 2cl
bond enthalpy can be symbolized by the
letters be so the bond enthalpy of the
chlorine chlorine single bond is equal
to positive 242 kilojoules per mole
and what this means is if we have one
mole of chlorine chlorine bonds it takes
positive 242 kilojoules of energy to
break those bonds
bond enthalpies are always positive
because it takes energy to break bonds
another name for bond enthalpy is bond
dissociation energy so you might see
this symbolized as bde
or just simply the letter d
bond enthalpies are often found in the
appendices of chemistry textbooks for
example we just saw the chlorine
chlorine single bond the bond enthalpy
is 242 kilojoules per mole whereas a
carb to break a carbon-carbon single
bond takes 348 kilojoules of energy per
mole of carbon-carbon single bonds
a carbon-carbon double bond has a bond
enthalpy of 614 kilojoules per mole
since a carbon-carbon double bond is
stronger than a carbon-carbon single
bond it takes more energy to break the
double bond and that's why the
carbon-carbon double bond has a higher
bond enthalpy
so the higher the value for the bond
enthalpy the stronger the bond notice
that these are average bond enthalpies
so the average bond enthalpy for a
carbon-carbon single bond is around 348
kilojoules per mole you might see
slightly different values for this
depending on which textbook you're
looking in but they're all pretty close
to the same value
the reason why these are average bond
enthalpies is because if we look at two
different molecules down here this is
ethane on the left and propane on the
right
if we break a carbon-carbon single bond
in ethane the bond enthalpy is slightly
different from breaking a carbon-carbon
single bond in propane and that's why we
we use average bond enthalpies
we've already seen that it takes energy
to break bonds so to break the chlorine
chlorine single bond and diatomic
chlorine gas takes positive 242
kilojoules per mole if it takes energy
to break bonds that means energy is
given off when bonds form
so when two individual chlorine gas
atoms come together to form
a chlorine chlorine bond so let's go
ahead and highlight that in here so this
bond is forming energy is given off the
magnitude of energy is still 242
kilojoules per mole however now we have
this negative sign in here to indicate
the energy is given off when bonds form
bond enthalpies can be used to estimate
enthalpies of reaction so to find the
change in the enthalpy for a chemical
reaction you take the sum of the bond
enthalpies of the bonds broken and from
that you subtract the sum of the bond
enthalpies of the bonds formed
the minus sign is in there because
energy is given off when bonds form
a good way to remember this equation is
to remember that b
comes before f in the alphabet so b
before f therefore it's bonds broken
minus bonds formed
let's use bond enthalpies to estimate
the enthalpy of reaction for the
following reaction here of methane with
chlorine gas to form chloromethane and
hydrogen chloride gas
it's often helpful to draw dot
structures for these kinds of problems
if we look at the methane dot structure
we would need to break one carbon
hydrogen single bond in order to get to
our products we would also need to break
a chlorine chlorine single bond
next one of the chlorines goes over to
the ch3
to form ch3cl so therefore we are
forming one carbon chlorine single bond
and the other cl goes with the hydrogen
so we also need to form one hydrogen
chlorine a single bond
the next step is to sum the bond
enthalpies of the bonds broken so let's
think about this for our reactants we're
breaking bonds so we have one mole of
methane reacting with one mole of
chlorine
and since we're breaking one
carbon-hydrogen single bond for every
one molecule of methane since we have
one mole of methane molecules we're
breaking one mole of carbon hydrogen
single bonds
therefore we can write down here one
mole of carbon hydrogen bonds
and the bond enthalpy for a carbon
hydrogen single bond is
413 kilojoules per mole
since there's one chlorine chlorine
single bond for every cl2 molecule and
we have one mole of chlorine molecules
we're breaking one mole of chlorine
chlorine single bonds so to this we're
going to add one mole of chlorine
chlorine single bonds and the bond
enthalpy for a chlorine chlorine single
bond is 242
kilojoules per mole
moles cancel out and we get that the sum
of the bond enthalpies of the bonds
broken is equal to 655
kilojoules
next we need to sum the bond enthalpies
of the bonds formed so we're forming one
mole of chloromethane and one mole of
hydrogen chloride gas
and since we're forming one carbon
chlorine single bond for every molecule
of chloromethane
since we're forming one mole of
chloromethane we're forming one mole of
carbon chlorine single bonds
so let's write down here we're forming
one mole of carbon chlorine bonds and
the bond enthalpy for a carbon chlorine
single bond is equal to 328
kilojoules per mole
and since we form one hydrogen chlorine
single bond for every molecule of
hydrogen chloride since we're making one
mole of hydrogen chloride we're forming
one mole of hydrogen chlorine single
bonds
so to this we add one mole of hydrogen
chlorine single bonds and the bond
enthalpy for a hydrogen chlorine single
bond is
431
kilojoules per mole
moles cancel and we get that the sum of
the bond enthalpies of the bonds formed
is equal to 759
kilojoules
next we're ready to find the change in
enthalpy for our chemical reaction the
sum of the enthalpy of the bonds broken
we found that was equal to 655
kilojoules and from that we subtract the
sum of the bond enthalpies of the bonds
formed which we found was
759 kilojoules so 655 minus 759 gives
negative 104
kilojoules
sometimes we see kilojoules or
kilojoules per mole or kilojoules per
mole of reaction kilojoules per mole of
reaction just means how the balanced
equation is written and let's see how we
can look at the units to get kilojoules
per mole of reaction when we do the
calculations
if we go back to breaking the carbon
hydrogen bond over here
we've seen there's one mole of carbon
hydrogen bonds that we need to break for
how the equation is written therefore we
can write a conversion factor of one
mole of carbon hydrogen bonds per one
mole of reaction as it's written and
then we multiply that by the bond
enthalpy is 413 kilojoules per mole for
a carbon-hydrogen bond this cancels out
moles of carbon-hydrogen bonds and this
gives us kilojoules per mole of reaction
as our units so it's more time consuming
to write it this way but we could do
that for all of our different bond
enthalpies to get kilojoules per mole of
reaction for the units for our final
answer when everything is under standard
conditions we need to add a superscript
of not so this would be the
standard change in enthalpy for a
chemical reaction so for the value we
just calculated negative 104 kilojoules
per mole of reaction
under this is under standard condition
so this is actually the standard change
in enthalpy for this chemical reaction
remember that bond enthalpies are only
averages and so this value that we
calculated is only an estimate for the
standard change in enthalpy for this
chemical reaction
a more accurate way of finding the
standard change in enthalpy for a
chemical reaction is to use standard
enthalpies of formation
and when you use standard enthalpies of
formation to find the standard change in
enthalpy for this particular chemical
reaction you get negative 99.8
kilojoules per mole of reaction so
negative 104 is pretty close to negative
99.8